para hablar de la teoría de colisión
consideremos la siguiente reacción aquí
tenemos el átomo a que reacciona con la
molécula de atómica bc para formar una
nueva molécula de atómica a p&c de
acuerdo a la teoría de colisión las
moléculas deben colisionar para
reaccionar así que en este ejemplo el
átomo a colisiones con la molécula pc
para que ocurra la reacción ahora las
colisiones deben tener la orientación
correcta para que sea efectiva por
ejemplo digamos que en esta reacción
tenemos nuestra molécula bc donde a
veces se acercan con esta orientación
como se forma un enlace entre a y b que
es lo que queremos podemos decir que
esta es la orientación correcta así es
como debe ser la colisión para que la
reacción pueda ocurrir pero si la
molécula bc se acerca del lado contrario
es decir tenemos a nuestro átomo y
después tenemos cp ahora el átomo se se
acerca al átomo ah pero esta no es la
orientación correcta entonces debe
existir una colisión pero que ocurra en
la orientación correcta
finalmente las colisiones deben tener la
energía suficiente si las colisiones no
tienen la energía suficiente los átomos
solamente rebotarán pero si hay mucha
energía
entonces las moléculas que colisionan
vibrarán más fuerte y romperán los
enlaces se los explicaré empezamos con
una cierta energía para nuestros
reactivos ésta es la energía de nuestros
reactivos
que son el átomo y la molécula de cee
podemos decir que la energía total es de
20 kilos urss por mol ahora cuando el
átomo y la molécula colisionan se
necesita mucha energía para romper el
enlace entre b y c y esa energía la
podemos encontrar en este diagrama
empezamos con 20 kilos por mol y
necesitamos llegar hasta 60 esa
diferencia es la energía que necesitamos
para que ocurra la reacción se le conoce
como energía de activación que se
aprecia como e
esta es la energía
de activación
y la energía de activación es muy
importante porque es la mínima cantidad
de energía que se necesita para iniciar
una reacción química para esta reacción
podemos ver que necesitamos llegar a 60
kilos urss por mol y empezamos con 20
entonces 60 menos 20 es igual a 40 la
energía de activación para esta reacción
es de 40 kilos por mol entonces la
energía de colisión debe ser mayor o
igual a la energía de activación y en
esta parte del diagrama tenemos un
estado de transición es decir que se
está formando un enlace entre a y b al
mismo tiempo que se rompe el enlace
entre b y c
a esto se le llama estado de transición
estado
de transición
o también lo pueden encontrar como
complejo activado
entonces aquí tenemos en las es
parciales el enlace entre b y c se está
rompiendo mientras que el enlace entre a
y b se está formando imaginen que esta
es una montaña y tenemos una pelota en
este valle necesitamos energía para
empujar la pelota hasta la cima
supongamos que tenemos energía para
empujar la pelota hasta aquí pero no es
suficiente la pelota se regresará
entonces por eso debemos pensar en la
energía suficiente para que las
moléculas no sólo choque porque si
tenemos la energía suficiente logramos
llevar nuestra pelota hasta la cima para
hacerla rodar por el otro lado y que
termine aquí que sería como la formación
de los productos entonces para este
ejemplo nuestros productos son la
molécula de atómica
y el átomo se y esta línea representa la
energía de estos productos y qué energía
tenemos bueno si nos vamos hacia acá
encontramos que la energía es de 10
kilos urss por mol así que en este
ejemplo la energía de los productos es
menor a la energía de los reactivos
empezamos con 20 kilos jules por mol y
terminamos con 10 kilos urss por mol
entonces el cambio de energía es igual a
la energía de los productos menos la
energía de los reactivos y en este
ejemplo la energía de los productos es
de 10 kilos urss por mol 10 menos
la energía de los reactivos que es de 20
kilos por mol diez menos veinte el
cambio de energía es igual a menos 10
que lo jules por móvil observen que
podemos ver este cambio de energía en el
diagrama este es el cambio de energía y
para este ejemplo del tae tiene un valor
negativo por lo tanto esta es una
reacción exotérmica se libera calor
recuerden que se necesita energía para
romper enlaces y se libera energía
cuando se forma y como liberamos calor
entonces este es el diagrama de energía
para una reacción exotérmica
ahora veamos otra reacción aquí tenemos
el avance de la reacción y empezamos con
la energía de nuestros reactivos
entonces esta es la energía de nuestros
reactivos que es de 20 kilos por mol y
sabemos que para llegar a este punto es
decir al estado de transición que está
en 80 kilos por mol necesitamos una
energía de activación
que para este ejemplo es de 80 menos 20
que es igual a 60 kilos jules por mol
entonces este es el estado de transición
y esto representa la energía de nuestros
productos
productos en este ejemplo la energía de
los productos es mayor a la energía de
los reactivos podemos decir que la
energía de los productos es de
aproximadamente 40 kilos urss por mol
entonces el cambio de energía es igual a
la energía de los productos menos la
energía de los reactivos esto es igual a
40 kilos
por moll menos 20 20 kilos por mol esto
nos da un cambio de energía igual a más
20 kilos jules
molt así que en este ejemplo tenemos un
cambio de energía positivo por lo tanto
es una reacción endo térmica el ejemplo
anterior era una reacción exotérmica
donde se libera calor y este es un
ejemplo de reacción en daughter mica se
absorbe calor